bilal franchement des très heureux de te
voir et le livre mobile al hassani
singulier tu parles de beaucoup beaucoup
de choses notamment à l'école tu dis que
c'était très dur pour toi arrêté l'école
à quel âge j'ai fait mon bac j'avais
fait un deal avec ma maman quand il
avait 8 ans on était en train de manger
du poisson et je lui ai dit maman moi je
vais être chanteur je me palais à
l'école c'est nul les maths
elle m'a dit tu oses tu vas t'entraîner
d'abord et tu passe ton bac et par tout
le monde et à ton bac tu fais ce que tu
veux c'est ça et donc on a tous une fois
j'ai tenu cette promesse j'ai eu un bac
l littéraire est bien sûr personne
singulier lagarde et michard et entendu
les lettres de mon moulin on a entendu
tout ça bien sûr j'en passe et des
meilleurs l ami de maupassant bel-ami ta
gueule
j'ai arrêté l'école j'ai fait trois
quatre mois d'université après ça m'a
saoulé assata saoul alors je dis tu dis
à l'école c'est toi qui le dit dans le
livre tu dis on te reprocher de rouler
du cul ouais j'ai je voulais pas du cuse
était déjà en fait j'avais sept ans à ce
moment là donc je sais même pas ce que
je fais ma démarche naturelle et il
trouvait que je marchais comme une fille
et j'ai eu cet épisode un peu
traumatisant pour moi que je raconte
dans un livre où j'étais à la piscine
municipale avec ma maman qui était loin
l'on en train de faire sa vie et mon
frère dans la piscine moi j'avais peur
de l'eau d'origine âgé pas et je voulais
aller aux toilettes et à mes camarades
de classe qui m'ont vu ils ont commencé
à se [ __ ] de moi mais arrivent très
très fort et j'étais un peu tout ça dans
mon truc je suis devenu tout rouge et
donc c'est là que j'ai commencé vraiment
à à à camoufler un petit peu mais là les
craintes que j'avais le fait que j'étais
triste parce que je pensais qu'être
triste c'était mauvais donc je garder la
tête haute et j'ai avancé comme ça
malgré le fait qu'ils étaient en train
de m'insulter et c'est là que j'ai
commencé un petit peu après c'est
certain
tony sipp hâtivement de confiance et
c'est vrai à bilad tu te livre vachement
dedans tu parle même de ta première fois
un oui c'est vous qui donnerez non si je
vous dis non mais oui mais deux minutes
ce que c'est bien sympa la demande et
des sandwiches mais c'est dur je vais
lire même si tu montes ses tubes ou fait
autant de sandwiches que tu disais de
bouquins je peux dire qu'aujourd'hui tu
présenteras foa post of conan
j'en parle j'en parle évidemment mais ce
n'était pas juste pour en parler j'avais
pas envie de parler de ma première fois
juste pour parler de ma première fois
c'était pas ce n'était pas le but mais
c'était vraiment cliquez ici pour toutes
les personnes qui vont quitter ça je
pense voilà je parle est un petit peu là
parce que moi j'étais un jeune garçon
qui commençait à découvrir sa sexualité
au collège et quand on est homosexuel
dans un dans un bahut où on est le seul
homosexuel
on n'a pas de relation il n'ya pas les
petites amourettes d'école on se tient
la main et on se fait le bisou sur la
joue et c'est moi j'avais pas le droit à
ça
et donc ça arrive à beaucoup de jeunes
qui sont dans mon cas est qui et qui
sont pas hétéro il voit d'un seul coup
confronté à l'aspect plus vulgaire en
fête de l'amour et à ce côté très sexuel
est en général
allez assez étonnante c'est que c'était
avec un garçon qui est avec qui et avec
une fiancée qui était avec un garçon qui
était ok c'est un garçon qui était avec
quelqu'un qui était quoi car elle est
une jeune fille était le monde aime je
suis désolé quitter ton qui était ton
ami oui et il paraît que voilà il s'est
dit voilà quel âge il à présent je crois
en 13 ans et demi et il paraît que
j'avais une aventure ensemble et après
il est retourné avec avec voilà et ça
s'est su et ça a créé des grosses
complications dans mon établissement
malgré le fait que c'était juste une
rumeur mais ce n'était pas vrai mais
voilà après on fait comme si c'était
vrai mais en gros pourrait pour le corps
à part à part lui et moi personne savait
si c'était vrai ou faux c'est un projet
sur ouï dire et donc tout le monde en
parlait et sabu congrès nsa a fait que
après ils m'ont dit de partir du nom
doit y aller cela j'ai dû quitter
l'établissement et pas lui juste moi et
donc c'était un peu compliqué après
voilà moi c'était à 13 ans j'étais très
jeune j'ai beaucoup de regrets par
rapport à ça dans ma tête je ne faisais
jamais que j'allais en parler
publiquement
mais si jamais plaisir c'est parce que
vraiment ce n'était pas quelque chose
que j'avais envie de faire et j'ai été
un petit peu mis dedans et c'était
c'était dur en fait à vivre mais sur le
moment je me rendais pas compte et avec
du recul je me rends compte que c'était
trop tôt en fait